so length on Carol
you're actually an astronomer by
training all of my degrees are in
astronomy and I've never been employed
as an astronomer but I've been
interested also in philosophy since I
started philosophy minor as an
undergraduate sat in on courses with
John Rawls and Robert Nozick as a
graduate student but I was told
correctly that I was a graduate student
you're supposed to not think about
anything other than what you were
studying but I've maintained interest in
these things I've written a couple of
papers about the relationship between
science and religion saying that being a
good scientist leads you to not be
religious and I did as a young assistant
professor a book publisher walked into
my office he was sort of tapping on
doors at the physics department at the
University of Chicago saying does anyone
wanna write a popular book and I said
well I don't have any plans but if I do
write a popular book I don't want it to
be about physics I want to write about
atheism and he was intrigued by that he
went back to his publisher and he came
back and said nobody would ever buy a
book about 80s so it turns out that was
wrong but I I think that various people
including people in this room have been
a wonderful job making atheism
naturalism an idea that the world is
what we observe and that's all that is
real much more out there in the public
discourse as we were talking about on
the car ride up there's some feeling
among many people that that explaining
why naturalism is right and how science
leads us to that pulls the rug out from
underneath you
in terms of why we are here what is the
purpose and meaning of life and so forth
and all we have to offer them in return
is a hard concrete floor and I don't
think that's true I think we can do
better but so I'm very very interested
in sort of taking those positive next
steps and explaining to people what it
is like to live
a world governed by naturalism and we
don't all agree you know we've had books
come out Sam Harris wrote a book that
was very interesting and he sends his
regrets he couldn't be here but he tried
to make the case that we can base
morality on science and some of us
disagree with that and but this is
something we should at least have an
informed set of perspectives about and
so I had the idea having this little
meeting like I was very very pleased at
the enthusiastic response that everyone
received so I'm very happy to have you
all here and if there's one thing I'm
willing to change my mind about
tentatively its free will so I know the
free will is one of the contentious
topics we can talk about I am a
compatible list I think that there's no
problem talking about free will even
though we're all made of atoms obeying
the laws of physics but my belief in
that is based on the idea that talking
about human beings as rational choice
making agents is the best theory we have
of talking about human beings at the
level of human beings so if someone
convinces me we have a better theory of
human beings in which they are not
making rational choices that I'm
certainly willing to change my mind
you